yeah what's up lads jesus christ derek
from london england what are you bumping
this on 22's man
unbelievable this guy's organs that can
we start over do you mind sorry
she got scared from the beginning i was
a shooting yeah what's up
my name is rob from london england
rob new mexico oh my god this week is
organs that double keyboard hitter
[Music]
is he from 1915
he's an organ donor give him a minute
yeah let me know what you guys think
um also brendan mate you look like your
ancestors recently
started coming out of the caves where
they've been living uh
thea you look like your ancestors have
recently stopped getting eaten by
brendan's ancestors
in september i think in manchester
game um gang gang buzz buzz all the best
boys
man here's the thing again are you from
1915 also the only organ i want to see
is in [ __ ]
uh god what is it oh phantom of the
opera yeah that's the only time it's
cool bro organ i like
the phantom of the opera is here
inside of me
that's pretty good huh i grew up with
that [ __ ] man
you just played non-stop really yeah i
know the whole album for some oh wow
weird that's the only time to hear org
hmm
i tell you what you ain't getting no
[ __ ] playing that thing
dude no one likes that thing you get a
lot of dick
i don't think so i think you're [ __ ]
a lot of ghosts
if you got that thing bro you're gonna
be
busted in a lot of [ __ ] you'd be
busting queen mary the third
oh bro you're gonna be [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] that has bats in it
you know you got that beautiful organ
dude
that dude oregon one of the top three
instruments of the 1920s
even before then bro that's 1700's bro
bro that's insane dude you don't play
that instrument
not drop the n word every day you know
i'm just really part of the times
in the 1700s they did we had it
yeah you might be right you might be
right you might be right we had it man
and then rappers took it from us
they did and now they claim it as theirs
um i what i do appreciate it's unique
okay i like that and uh maybe he can
catch a
ghost spy in his web look any chick that
ever liked that movie with robert
pattinson in it
yucking [ __ ] him twilight yeah well
sign me up
so obviously you can [ __ ] it it's
twilight fan
gang baby
so yeah bro obviously you just need to
roll up to a bram stoker convention
with that thing in the back interview
with the vampire with his dick
i'm in bro yeah bro you got it dude i
think
uh i'm gonna say kangan on oregon